let's understand a few jargons used in
probability
and we take the most common example of
the role of a dice
these are the six possible outcomes or
possibilities
you can either roll a one or a two or a
three and so on up to six
remember you're rolling just one dice so
you will get any one of these six
options all these outcomes together form
something called the sample space
and each outcome is called a sample
point
one is the sample point two is a sample
five is the sample point and so on
now assume you're asked the probability
of getting a number less than three at
one through of a dice
look at the outcomes and decide
which ones will result in a number less
than three these two outcomes are the
only possibilities
it can only be these two outcomes one or
two
that becomes our event
these are the only three things you will
use very often in probability
let's review what we just learnt
we saw what a sample space is it can be
defined as all possible outcomes
then we saw what a sample point means
a sample point is one possible outcome
any one outcome from all possible
outcomes
and then we came to an event
and an event can be defined as one or
more of the possible outcomes